cette semaine le magazine télé 2
semaines qui en ce moment au kiosque a
révélé lors d'une grande enquête les
salaires bruts des présentateurs
chroniqueurs et comédien à la télé on va
vous révéler les chiffres il ya une
grosse partie de l' enquête qui porte
sur les chroniqueurs de tpm paix et de
balances ton post on vous a fait un
petit récap et vous allez voir sartec
pour assouvir notre curiosité télé 2
semaines a publié une enquête sur le
salaire des stars de la télé on y
découvre par exemple que l'animatrice de
tf1 karine ferri en poche 1500 euros par
tirage du loto incroyable à cyril féraud
quant à lui serait payé 650 euros par
numéro de slam sur france 3 en tâchant
ça génial
bully-les-mines animateur star de france
2 gagnerait 2000 euros par émission
présentée un tarif proche de celui d'un
certain benjamin castaldi qui
empocherait jusqu'à 4000 euros par prime
animé sur ces huit dans la liste des
chroniqueurs toujours on apprend qu'eric
naulleau toucherait 1800 euros par
prestation dans balances ton post quant
à valérie benaïm elle serait rémunéré
1200 euros par émission en moyenne un
chroniqueur de tpm pays empocherait
entre 150 et 1500 euros par émission
côté jury dans les émissions de
divertissement les tarifs explosent
jennifer aurait été payée 500 mille
euros pour prêter son oreille à the
voice 200000 euros par saison pour chris
marquez et ses prestations dans danse
avec les stars
quant à miss france elle empocherait
4200 euros par mois
enfin le chiffre qui est peut-être le
plus surprenant est celui des stars de
la télé réalité qui en plus de vacances
au soleil en poche chaque semaine autour
de 1500 euros
franchement achard est rongé bail comme
quoi ça paye de s'engueuler et wind me
alors on a vu tout on a vu tous les
salaires secoue sa pelouse mater les
enquêtes sur les salaires est ce que ça
vous intéresse sur les salaires des
comédiens des chroniqueurs alors on a vu
ils disent aussi dans lequel je vous lis
le journaliste ne révèle pas le salaire
il a dit je ne révèle pas le salaire
d'arthur de nagui ni de cyril hanouna
car difficile à établir avec avec
précision voilà donc voilà il n'y pas
voilà donc je dis voilà il est donc
valérie benaïm jory d'audience artec je
me rends compte surtout que benjamin
quatre fois plus payer que moi comptons
alors mais c'est lors il kinkanda misumi
et sonores ils ont une fourchette très
très large alors vous n'étiez pas à bras
j'adore moi excusez moi et benjamin
castaldi qui n'a d'ailleurs pas eu le
courage de venir aujourd'hui il gagne
4000 euros par prime socama vrai parce
que in april a jamais confirmé attendait
masse et il va nous le dire
le prague sur les
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jamais j'espère à rembourser alors c'est
vrai alors on rigole et ce sont des
sommes astronomiques 1 on va pas se
mentir c'est vrai voilà et il faut
savoir benjamin castaldi vous savez que
quand ils ont été touchés pour une
saison de loft story époque il touché
600 mille euros pour la saison bon c'est
comme les joueurs de foot faut voir
combien ça rapporte au fait que les
carrières sur les sponsors et les
tunnels où ça vous choque ce genre de
gros salaires ou pas franchement non pas
du tout parce que je sais le travail que
sa demande derrière parce qu'il ya plein
de gens des ya plein de français qui
travaille très très dur qui ont des
travail la pénibilité très très fort et
qu'ils ont les six qui se disent mine de
rien nous on travaille on travaille le
matin à 6 heures on touche le soir on
est fracassée à la balade
on ne rentre le soir à 19h ondes et
fracasse la mine de rien on gagne ça
faut pour par mois et canton c'est vrai
que moi et mes lui gagne 4000 euros mais
combien de temps il travaille pas nous
on est des acteurs de ya des moments où
pendant six sept voire huit mois on ne
travaille pas du tout et eon gagnait 10
milles sur un coup et mais il faut
savoir manger pendant des mois je veux
que vous connaissez bien moi c'est là
elle sait pas gérer la dalle ça fait
longtemps je suis pas monté sur scène
j'ai mis de côté on m'a pris non mais
c'est pareil non mais c'est la dernière
fois que suis monté sur scène avait
presque quoi un an
d'accord bah comment tu vas à côté ouais
bien sûr oui bon c'est vrai que ces
déchets après après c'est vrai que je
vois que vous me connaissez mal l'équipe
de touche pas à mon poste
/ amy quand il travaille travaille
jamais je préfère vous dirigez
l'audition et puis pour être honnête
reconduit castaldi game 4 me mais je
crois que c'est sur facture c'est exact
oralair exactement pareil qu ils
viennent comme le paf à peu près voilà
ça fait à peu près de 8500 euros
et moi je moi je moi je mal parce que
voilà malade le cerf des autres ça
m'intéresse donc ça ne me choque pas
qu'on me demande mon salaire à moi tout
ça honnêtement tu mon salaire ne
touchent pas en poche le christ sont 700
euros par émission
voila voila merci match que j'avais je
le sais je connais même pas les salaires
de choses se calment
[Rires]
ces crimes dans sur plaisante je sais
j'ai commencé à me les gc ca on
privilégie position par émission mais de
ce que tu me donne je donne la moitié a
gelé tant ce que tu me non tu sais il ya
des gens qui appellent au téléphone et
qui se font passer pour l'état cette
attention à ça mais la première oui
c'est quoi je donne la moitié de ce que
je gagne chez toi à une association qui
s'occupe de pauvres par exemple de biens
m'a parlé d'un cas de durée des gens qui
quittent téléphone et qui se ferait
passer pour la plusieurs il aurait aussi
des gens qui essaient l'association
dissimulerait vendre des terrains à
l'étranger quand tu arrives n'y a pas de
bourse évoqué un lobby turc et sur
capital de ce que les gens voient
bravo vous avez vous les enquêtes sur
les salles et oui je sais je m'en fous
complètement mais tout ça on en parle
des salaires depuis la jean luc delarue
avec le scandale isation prosateur alors
faut dire aussi que celle impliquant la
ferai parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui sont dans l'audiovisuel
qui n'ont pas l'ombre de ce qui est dit
là et en plus il ya une grande
différence aussi avec la presse écrite
et en presse écrite souvent des gens
naissent de presse écrite qui sortent
ces infos parce que ça n'a rien à voir
non plus avec les mêmes tarifs en presse
écrite ça n'a rien après bercy jacky
mois jacques est ce que toi tu étais
t'intéresser salaire tu vas tu es tu
pour attaquer dans la télé depuis
longtemps tu reconnais voit la cdc les
fourchettes que du oui je trouve ça
normal
tu te sens tu mets tout le monde et tu
mets même les gens la télé réalité 2
ouais ouais voilà là tu les as tu le
sors faire impression toi même travail